its name is a mouthful the starting
point law for argentine's Freedom or the
Omnibus law for short Congress is now
debating its 633 articles aimed at
transforming Argentina's current welfare
state into what could become the world's
most deregulated free market
system this is a fundamental and
necessary step to overcome our decadent
situation if the law is not approved
there will be unpredictable consequences
it's economic and social shock therapy
allowing president cavier M to reduce
pensions privatize Health Care sell off
State companies reform electoral and
labor laws even the right to strike
there's even an article to oblige judges
to wear black robes and use a gavel to
open and close a court ceremony all this
under the umbrella of a state of
emergency that would give the president
extraordinary power powers to basically
bypass Congress for up to four years M
who likes to paint himself as a kind of
Lion King has said that in a democracy a
president is like an emperor and that is
exactly what many critics say he is
trying to become if he can manage to get
the approval of
Congress Marcos Novado believes mle
won't get what he
wants despite M's desire to become a
Caesar I don't think Argentina's
democracy is at risk he has too little
power in Congress and his followers are
too disorganized to be a
threat while Congress debates
workingclass argentines wonder how long
they'll have to swallow M's painful
medicine before their sick economy
improves with triple digit inflation an
M's recent 183% devaluation of the
currency Patricia hasn't sold a single
pair of shoes
today
this is all I could afford to buy to
feed my family of five for the next two
days how can I tell my children to eat
dry bread while we wait for better
days an extreme crisis requires extreme
Solutions says the president for now
most seem resigned to bite the bullet
for as long as they can Lucia Newman Al
jazer
buenosaires make sure to subscribe to
our channel to get the latest news from
Al jaaz